SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to IS3600, our intro
to Cloud computing course.
My name is Dr. Sharad
Jones, I'm a professor here
in the department.
And I'm really
excited to be teaching
this course with you guys.
This is one of
those topics that--
I think every class,
every professor
will say that the
content is always
changing, but this one
even more so than others.
Even to say broadly
that we're teaching
a course in Cloud computing
is a bold and broad statement.
As you'll see this
semester, Cloud computing
is such a big topic.
It's so wide ranging that
we're going to only scratch
the surface of this, but I
hope it at least introduces you
to enough tools and techniques
that you kind of fundamentally
understand how most modern
websites and online companies
work, and also the
kind of opportunities
here to innovate in this space.
So again, it is truly ubiquitous
across basically every area
of tech.
I don't think there's any
company you'll come across,
honestly, whether tech or
not, that isn't leveraging
some bit of Cloud resources.
As we'll see again,
pretty much anything
that is connected
to the internet
now has to use Cloud resources.
It's the only way
we can really scale.
And so having an understanding
of these tools and resources
across these platforms
I think will really
help you get the bigger
picture of this all.
Now, for those that
I haven't met before,
you might recognize
this picture here.
This is my wife.
She's also a professor in the
department, Dr. Carly Fox.
So definitely reach
out to me or her
if you ever have any issues
that we can help out with.
But to give a bit
more background
on me, and maybe kind of my
journey in Cloud computing
and how I kind of
got to this point--
here, I'll slide myself out of
the way, so I'm not blocking it.
I don't want to
block my dog either.
That's my dog, Mico.
You'll probably see
plenty of pictures of him
throughout this semester.
But yeah, so again, I did
my undergraduate degree
at Rice University
down in Houston, Texas
in astronomy before
moving on to Carvana.
So timeline here you kind of see
2014, I was at Rice and then--
or I finished up at
Rice there and then
I started at Carvana as a
smaller tech startup there.
And that was about where I
started to dabble in the Cloud.
We were a growing tech company.
We were leveraging a lot
of compute resources,
and the scale of data
we were working with
was becoming just
so hard to deal
with in our local environment.
And we'll talk
about why that is,
and I'll give some concrete
examples from my experience
there of why we needed to
transition at least aspects
of the business to the Cloud.
But again, I'll say,
recognize that my background
is very heavily in the
data science space.
So after that I went on to
Maxar as a data scientist
and did my PhD in statistics.
And I worked for another startup
after that in the data science
space.
So my experiences
in the Cloud are
going to be heavily focused--
or I'll say at least the most
robust in this area of data
science.
But I definitely don't want that
to skew you and make you think
that it's only useful there.
And actually, as
we'll see, we'll
talk about data science and
machine learning and how
we can leverage the
Cloud there, but we'll
cover so many other
things that are related
to a bunch of other jobs.
I don't have the
expertise in those areas
as much, so I'll do my best to
make sure to explain how it's
used in these different areas.
But I'll say broadly that we
have a lot of really cool things
that we can do with the
Cloud, and in data science
specifically, where we're
working with large data sets
kind of processing
data at scale,
you really need the flexibility
of these sorts of platforms.
So I'll jump really quick, some
housekeeping on the syllabus.
Broadly, this course will be,
again, for these kind of online
lectures here, you'll
have alternating--
or you'll have-- it should
be in the modules here.
So you'll see this breakdown
of lectures, associated
assignments.
We won't discussions,
necessarily.
I've switched that out.
So these are grayed out for you.
You'll see that-- that's
just showing me for here.
So I view this as a
student really quick
and you can see what this
will look like for you.
So you should see again,
lecture one, lecture two,
and within there there'll
be the content of the videos
and then the associated
assignment for each
of those modules or
each of those units.
So should be pretty
straightforward in how
it's laid out.
But again, if you have
issues or questions,
please just reach out.
Happy to answer those.
But moving more
towards that, we'll
have homeworks and unit
projects as the main components
of this course.
These homework
assignments will typically
be shorter tasks
associated directly
with what we're talking
about in the videos.
Whereas the unit projects will
require you to take something
we've talked about and
apply it to a larger scale.
It'll be somewhere between
five and six unit projects that
are related basically to the
different units in this course,
but you'll see that
laid out there as well.
There's a little flexibility
towards the end, that's
why I say again of five or six,
we'll see where it ends up at.
And then as far as the
final project goes,
this is something that
I'll talk much more
about as the semester
goes on, but I do want
you to start thinking about it.
My goal for this final project
is actually not to have you--
or I'll say it this way.
I don't have a
lot of constraints
on this final project.
I want you to do something
that is of interest to you that
leverages the Cloud.
That's the extent of it.
Now, certainly, I want you
to highlight your skills.
I want this to basically be
your bullet point on the resume
to say like, hey, here's my
understanding of the Cloud
and what I got out of
this course in the intro
to Cloud computing.
So I'll have a
check in point kind
of halfway through the semester
where you all submit proposals.
So I can read through them, see
if you are on the right track,
or maybe if the
scope is too large.
That's typically
what happens is--
and that's not a bad
thing, but you guys
will have big, broad goals.
I'll try to help
you figure out what
pieces that we can bite off.
And so I don't want you to
take that to mean you shouldn't
have some big goal in mind.
And actually, I love if you do.
There's no expectation
that if you say,
hey, I want to build
the next Netflix
and by the end of the
semester, all that happens
is you have a website live
with a few links on it.
I think that'd be awesome.
I think that's
success because you've
taken meaningful steps
towards that larger end goal.
So very, very flexible.
But I'll just say
keep an eye out
for this, start
thinking about this.
Start thinking about topics
that are of interest to you
as we're going through
our individual examples
in this class.
Moving further on through here.
Important details.
Office hours.
Keep an eye on this.
This is subject to change.
So I wouldn't quote these
numbers here, but just
pull up Canvas, pull
up the syllabus when
you're looking at this, and
you'll be able to see the office
hours here.
These are designated
times that I
will be online, kind
of available to hop
on Zoom for office hours--
or you can come by my office.
I'm in the Eccles Business
Building office 712.
But if you are unavailable
those times or those
don't work for you, you
kind of work at those times,
you need to meet in the evenings
or whatever it might be,
that's perfectly fine.
Just shoot me an email at
least 24, 48 hours in advance,
and we'll be able to
find some time to meet.
I'm generally
flexible, so just let
me know when one works for you.
And then finally, as far as
breakdown goes to the grade,
you'll see that
the final product
is a large chunk of the grade.
So again, I want that
to be a real focus
throughout the semester.
But certainly, the unit projects
and homework assignments
will impact that as well.
So keep an eye on this.
Again, syllabus always
subject to change,
but that's broadly what
I'd say regarding that.
So let's switch back
really quick then.
And also say, I'd love for you
to reach out in general just
to introduce yourself.
That's always the hard part
about teaching online courses,
is I don't get to see you guys
in person, get to know you
and understand what
your interests are.
So if you ever have some time,
either pop by office hours,
shoot me a message on email.
I tend to respond to emails more
than I respond to-- or faster
than I respond to Canvas
messages, so I prefer that.
But yeah, I just love to get
to know you and understand
your goals in this course.
So jumping right into it then.
I put this slide
here specifically
because whether you
realize it or not,
the important detail about
a Cloud computing course
is understanding what it
means to use a computer,
and really what a computer is,
because it will highlight why
we have limitations or
where the opportunities are,
working both on premise
and in the Cloud.
So to just step back broadly,
the three main things
we're going to worry about
as far as a computer goes
in this course is
the CPU, memory,
and any sort of accelerators.
The CPU, that is the
central processing unit.
That is the general
purpose computer.
That's what this image here
of this AMD Ryzen chip shows.
That is what a CPU looks like.
This is a chip that
can process a lot
of different types of tasks.
They might be multi-core.
You'll hear that, multi-threaded
as well on top of that.
But you can think about that as
how many independent operations
can they do.
It's not exact.
There's a bunch of
details in there
we're kind of glossing over.
But in the context of how
that relates to accelerators,
it's important to understand
that the number of cores
is related to how many tasks
can be done in parallel.
To skip over memory
for a second,
just explain accelerators.
Accelerators are
things like GPUs,
so graphics processing units.
If you're a computer
gamer, you're
very well or very familiar
with graphics processing units,
but they've actually become
a very important tool
across computing and the
tech industry in general
in recent years.
The reason being is, as
I said before, a CPU can
do as many operations roughly
in parallel as there are cores.
So a standard laptop, like
my laptop right now I work on
has eight cores, let's say.
That means that if I have eight
mathematical operations that
need to happen, maybe eight
multiplication steps or I'm
multiplying eight different
sets of numbers together,
I can run each of
those in parallel
and then summarize the
results at the end.
That's good.
And a multiplication
operation is
so fast that would feel
like light speed anyways.
But if it's a complex
task, it might actually
be something where I'm a
little bit bottlenecked.
These processes take a while,
and I can only do eight of them,
eight operations in parallel.
Well, something
like a GPU or TPU,
which is a very specific
chip designed by Google,
it's called a tensor
processing unit,
but it roughly runs
on the same idea,
these are designed to have
thousands, tens of thousands
of cores.
They're not as general
purpose, of course,
where a CPU can open
up a Word document,
edit it and do all
these sorts of things,
a GPU certainly
can't do that, but it
can do very quick mathematical
operations, a multiplication
step.
And this actually
comes from the fact
that graphics, in video
games, are inherently
a bunch of little
multiplication operations.
So when we started to
move towards things
like neural networks and machine
learning, which themselves are
also a bunch of little
multiplication operations,
researchers realized that we
could leverage these GPUs down
to dramatically accelerate it.
If I need to do--
take something like a ChatGPT.
Those have trillions
of parameters.
Each of those
parameters needing to be
multiplied by other
numbers as we're
trying to make predictions.
Well, if I have
eight cores, then
I can only do eight operations
in parallel or eight
of those trillions of
operations in parallel,
versus if I have something
like a GPU or TPU,
I can really dramatically
speed up the compute here.
Now, the important detail
in the context of the Cloud
is that if I were to do
this on, let's say, a GPU
that I had here at home, right.
I have a GPU in my computer.
I'd be a little limited.
A big 4090 GPU is probably
the largest consumer GPU
as of this recording.
That is going to cost you
somewhere around $2,000,
maybe $1,500 to $2,000.
And I might have a process,
again, something like a ChatGPT,
trying to train a
model like ChatGPT
that might take hundreds,
thousands of GPUs
to really meaningfully get
done in a short amount of time.
And so now all of
a sudden, I mean,
it's just
incomprehensibly expensive
to purchase all those
resources, but I
can leverage Cloud
resources to rent those,
and we'll talk about
why that-- or how
that works in a little bit.
But to not drag on
this point too long,
to briefly talk
about memory, which
we'll spend a whole week on.
There's two types of memory
we'll discuss in this class.
One of those is kind
of volatile memory,
so RAM, you'll hear me refer
to as RAM almost always.
And the other is
non-volatile memory,
and that'll be your hard drive
or your solid state drive.
RAM, think about that as
the working memory, that
is how much kind of
information I can hold,
kind of readily available to
use or operate on right now.
And when I shut my computer
off, that's going to disappear.
It's not going to
be existing anymore.
Versus my hard drive or
my solid state drive,
that is my long term storage.
So if I want to save
pictures on my hard drive,
that's what we're
talking about there.
So that's just designed to
hold it there and be really
cheap and efficient to store a
lot of information, versus RAM.
It's going to be more
expensive for equivalent
volumes of memory, but it'll be
much, much faster as far as read
and write speeds, and so I can
operate on it more quickly.
So anyway, that's all to say,
that is the core components
of the computer we're
worried about in the context
of this course.
And then if you put all those
pieces together, put all those
together into one
box, and then you
can see here as
this rack shows, I
can stack a bunch of
those boxes together
and basically just connect a
bunch of computers together.
And really, that is
fundamentally what a server is.
So you might have heard
this term a server before.
But even-- again, we
mentioned Netflix before.
Netflix has to be
hosted somewhere.
I have to have those videos
saved, some of those movies
saved somewhere.
I have to have the website,
the code of the website saved
somewhere.
And that's what a
server does for me,
is it allows me to basically
say, OK, well, this computer has
the code for it.
All of these servers, all
these racks within the server,
they have all the videos.
And so therefore, when somebody
comes to visit netflix.com,
what they're actually doing is
sending a request to the server,
and that server is sending
the relevant information back.
So very, very useful.
These are the types
of things that we'll
use for gaming, for hosting
websites, hosting applications,
storing data, whatever
that might be.
A server is really just
a computer that is--
or a bunch of computers
stacked together.
So nothing crazier than that.
And really what we can
have is, we can have--
I mean, again, when I was at
Carvana, we had our own servers.
Before we were even
leveraging the Cloud,
we had a room
filled with servers,
looked something like this.
A bunch of blinking
boxes in a room.
And we could reasonably serve
all the content on our website
from those servers, but
there are some limitations.
So let's look at
what that means.
So again, as we said, take
our Netflix example here.
Maybe we have another
season of Stranger Things.
Let's say it's Stranger
Things season 6, 10, whatever
we're at, at this point.
That has to be-- that is
a video, that is a file.
That has to be
uploaded somewhere.
So let's say that gets
uploaded from the studio
up to our server.
So now it's sitting
on our server here.
And then we're sitting
there on our couch
and we want to watch that video.
We send a request and that
request returns a response.
That response is the video
itself for us to watch.
Again, that is
fundamentally what it looks
like to deploy an application.
And in this context,
we're talking
about doing this on premise.
That word on premise
means the premise
is being this location
that we're at here,
and we're managing those
physical resources.
So we've purchased
the computers,
we've plugged them
into our outlets,
we're paying for the power,
the cooling, all that stuff.
That's what an on
premise deployment is.
And you'll hear me
use that term a lot.
Pros and cons to that.
There are some really
good pros, actually,
and there's a lot of discussion
around this right now
in general, which we'll get
into later in the semester
about the value of Cloud
computing or Cloud resources
versus on premise resources.
But one big value of them
is they're fixed costs.
Once I've purchased
a server, I know--
that cost me an amount of
money, and I'll put it there
in my room and
outside of, again,
ongoing energy costs or cooling
costs, the costs are fixed.
I've spent the amount of money
and that's what it costs me.
Things aren't going
to necessarily go
up or down in a large swing,
so that could be valuable.
They also can have
very low latency.
So if my users,
let's say, again, I
have a server at my company
that is there for my employees
to leverage for whatever
their tasks are, well,
if it's right around
the corner from us,
we can run a hard
wire directly to it.
That's going to be infinitely
faster than anything
else we can do over the web.
And that can really help out
from a security standpoint,
if we, for example, have to
have very sensitive information.
If I'm a bank account or anybody
that might be storing very, very
sensitive information,
I can physically,
or especially in the context
of national security,
you'll see this a
lot, where servers
will be housed in a room with
no physical connections anywhere
outside of power, maybe.
They're not going to be
connected via ethernet
to any outside room.
That means that even if your
entire company or organization
is compromised, if there's
nothing physically connected
there, there's an air gap.
And so that can be a very
secure way to deploy resources.
You don't have to move
sensitive information around.
And again, even if there's
an internet outage,
if it's over there
in the room, you
can just go run over
and connect to it.
So there's some values there.
But again, that comes with
a bunch of associated cons.
You do have to pay for energy
consumption, cooling resources.
You do have to have
a physical space.
And this is the really
big one, is that you
need to size it appropriately.
If you have constant variations
in your demand of resources,
your website gets visited
a lot one week of the year,
but then the rest of the
year, it's never used,
you have to size it
for the largest amount
of users that you'll expect, and
the rest of the time you're just
paying for unused resources.
You're at risk for power outages
or any sort of physical damage
to the building.
And again, you now
need to staff people
to maintain, upgrade,
backup all the resources
that you have on site.
So pros and cons.
And that's what really
brings us to Cloud computing,
is Cloud computing
says, well, what
if instead of doing
on premise deployment,
we took all those servers and
put them in a big data center
somewhere else, and we
just connect to that.
And we share that with a bunch
of other people too, right.
We share that with
every other company
that needs resources,
needs Cloud resources
or needs servers.
And this is why I wanted
to explain it this way,
is just to clarify that
the Cloud as we discuss it
can seem kind of like
this ephemeral thing.
But really all we're saying
when we talk about the Cloud
is a bunch of servers
connected to the internet.
We can connect to those
servers because we
have an internet connection,
and so therefore, we
have access to the Cloud.
That's all it is at its core--
a server in a room somewhere.
And it's just that
it's not on premise.
If that same server
that's stored by Amazon
is instead on our local
site, we wouldn't call it
the Cloud necessarily.
You might call it a personal
Cloud or something like that,
if you connect to the internet.
But really, that's the only
thing we're talking about here.
And you also see that
it's not an either/or.
We talked about on
premise deployment,
that's getting this
private Cloud idea.
You could have an entirely
Cloud-based platform,
and then yeah, you're
just a Cloud company.
But in reality,
most organizations
are in this kind
of hybrid approach
where some things
are in the Cloud,
some things are on premise.
You that's how we
work Carvana as well.
We still maintain
on premise servers
for a variety of
reasons and use cases,
and we also had our
remote resources.
I won't spend too
much time on this
because we're going to have a
whole lecture around this topic,
but I also just
wanted to highlight
that the way I've been
describing it kind of
falls into this bucket of what
is often called infrastructure
as a service.
This is where we just
treat it as like,
there's a computer in the Cloud.
But in reality,
there's a gradient.
We could be leveraging
Cloud resources just to say,
I need access to computer
or storage in the Cloud.
But we could also say,
hey, actually what
I want is a platform
that allows me to build
my resources on Cloud,
on a Cloud platform,
but I'm not actually managing
the underlying computers.
Or take that to
the other extreme,
and then we could look at
software as a service, where
that's just saying, hey, we
have basically no control
over the resources.
Think about something
like Google Docs.
That is a software as a service.
It is a Cloud resource, right.
I can connect to it, I can
edit my document remotely,
but it is entirely in the Cloud.
And also, I'm not interacting
with the underlying compute
resources.
So again, there are some real
benefits to Cloud computing.
Basically, take all those cons
of on premise resources and you
have all the pros
of Cloud resources.
I pulled out this example here.
It's an interesting one.
Basically, this was a case
where the New York Times wanted
to basically scan
in all the high--
or do high resolution scans
of all their newspapers from
the 1800s on.
So massive amount of
information, a ton of--
I mean, again, these are
very high resolution scans.
So they're very large
files, and it's every page.
So it was a very compute
intensive process.
The on premise solution would
say, OK, well, have a scanner
here at your desk, run each
of the images through there
and then store them, basically,
onto your local computers
in the office, and you
need to have enough storage
on in your office to do that.
And you also only have
one computer to do this.
So you've done all
your scans already,
so that process is done.
That has to happen
no matter what.
But now when you want to process
them, maybe edit the colors,
adjust this and put them
into certain storage system,
that all has to be done
through your computer.
What they did instead was
they leveraged the Cloud.
They said, hey,
well, what we can do
is we can spin up 100 computers,
a hundred virtual computers,
we call them virtual machines,
and they spun up a hundred
of those and did all the
processing in parallel.
So they ran all their-- or
they split up all their files
and said, hey, each of
these 100 virtual machines
will take some chunk
of our repository
here and then push that live
and store it in the Cloud
as well, too.
And that caused them--
I think the estimate was
something like 900 bucks to do.
Took about 24 hours, 900
bucks in Cloud resources,
which is not cheap.
But if you factor in that they
used 100 different computers.
I mean, even if these were 100
pretty cheap computers at $500
a piece, you'd already still
be spending-- what is that?
$50,000 on just computers alone.
So, I mean, it's just
so wildly valuable
to be able to scale up
almost limitless resources.
You're basically trading
off this capital expense,
this upfront cost for
variable expenses.
This might not seem
that powerful yet,
but imagine tomorrow you wanted
to start a company that might--
start a website, let's say, that
might have to scale globally.
If you just bought your own
servers to host that website,
you would have to upfront
buy as big of a computer
as you could afford or as much
as you needed for your user
base, versus with the
Cloud, you would just
purchase the bare minimum for
what you need right now, and as
that user base
increases, it's very easy
to just scale that
up automatically.
That resource pooling
like we talked about
before, where we say,
hey, rather than us having
a bunch of single on premise
servers, every company
having their own
on premise servers,
we pool all these resources
into a few big Cloud providers,
and now their goal
is to optimize
the utilization of this.
They don't want to have a bunch
of unused resources sitting
around.
So if I've rented 100
computers to use for 24 hours,
they're going to make sure
that when I'm not using that,
somebody else is using
those compute resources.
So they're going to
maximize availability to me,
but minimize the
unused resources, which
really allows them to
dramatically cut costs on that.
So from my side of
it, it's really nice.
No matter what task I have to
do from a compute perspective,
I just assume I have
infinite resource.
I assume I have infinite
computers, or at least
as much as I can afford, because
I can just, one button click,
spin up a massive computer or
dozens of massive computers
using the Cloud.
So it's a lot of power.
Great power, great
responsibility, right?
So we will be intentional on
how we utilize and manage that,
though.
It's on demand and
self-service, so we
are the ones in charge of that.
We say, hey, I want to spin
up these computers now,
I get to click the buttons.
I don't have to call somebody
and wait for this to happen.
I can just manage, spin up, spin
down, keep track of the usage,
all that sort of stuff myself.
I don't have to worry
about maintenance at all.
If there are some machines
that are going bad,
they swap them out.
I don't notice that if
I'm leveraging these Cloud
resources.
We'll also talk about
the security value
that comes with that,
and that they duplicate
across multiple locations.
So even if there's an
earthquake in one area,
my information can be
duplicated across so many areas
that I'm never going
to notice that issue.
It's completely automatic.
So again, I can have a business
that maybe all of a sudden
sees some massive spike
in growth overnight.
I can set up my services
or my servers in the Cloud,
such that they automatically
adjust to that.
So as long as it stays
below what I can afford,
I can scale up to any number of
users basically instantaneously,
and I can do this
globally, because there
are data centers on every corner
of this globe pretty much now.
And all that leads to it being
just a very economical solution.
You're only paying
for what you need.
That's not a complete
solution, there are still
issues with that, and we'll talk
about some of these challenges,
but broadly speaking, a
ton of benefits associated.
But in the same breath, while
I say they are very secure,
that security also means that--
or from a consolidation
standpoint,
that also means there is
a security vulnerability
in that all of our
resources are isolated
to one place in the Cloud, or
all to one set of resources.
If my company is
leveraging AWS, which
we're going to use in this
class, Amazon Web Services,
if I have admin privileges to my
users-- or my company's account
and I lose my password or
somebody gets my password,
they could technically take
down our whole business.
So there are some really
intentional security steps
we need to take to make sure
that our platform stays secure,
because now we've kind of
consolidated all to one thing,
right.
It's not just a bunch of
servers sitting in our office,
it's a single website
you have to log into.
Similarly, and again,
I'll preface this
and say that these
platforms are very secure.
They heavily focus on ensuring
privacy and reliability
of the platform.
There is still a risk in that
we are transferring information
over the internet and it's being
stored in a Cloud repository,
as compared to as
we talked about,
an air gapped thing where we
have a server in an isolated
room, locked room, no windows,
no connection to the internet.
It will never match
that level of security.
So again, there is some
trade off a bit with that.
And we've seen
this as well, too,
that there have been
massive outages and breaches
of these Cloud platforms.
But you've probably
noticed this,
days when you get on the
internet or open up your phone
and like, 35% of your apps
don't work for whatever reason,
that's probably because there
was some major outage on one
of these large Cloud
providers that took out
a good chunk of the internet.
So that can happen, but
again, rare occurrences.
And also while I said that
these platforms are economical,
this cost, again,
if you have very--
and this is some of these
articles are talking about
is an example of one company
that chose to leave the Cloud,
and we'll talk about this
more later on this semester.
But for them, their
argument was basically
we understand how many users we
have, we don't expect growth,
we have very predictable
growth in our business.
And so we'd rather actually
trade off those fixed costs,
the variable costs.
There is variation in pricing
on platforms like AWS.
And so instead, if
they just purchase
some cheap resources, some
cheap servers themselves,
manage and maintain them,
it can reduce costs overall.
So it really is a question of
not necessarily is it cheaper
to be on premise
or in the Cloud,
it's more a question of
where your business is at
and how you all
operate, which platform
or which approach is
the most valuable.
And this is related to
that, it is to say like,
once you've put all your
resources in the Cloud,
especially consolidated to--
and you usually benefit from
consolidating to a single vendor
like AWS or Google.
Once you've centralized all
to AWS or all to Google,
it's really hard to
switch out of that.
It's really hard to
say, well, now I'm
going to actually migrate
to a cheaper solution
or I'm going to migrate on
premise, because there's
just so much effort in standing
those up and spending those down
that typically once
you get bought in,
it's rare that people want
to leave these platforms.
So it's something to
consider as you're
leveraging any of these tools.
And finally-- I think
this last point.
Yeah, this is one where it's
kind of a pro and con as well.
All these are gray areas.
I mean, by its nature, one of
the values of taking this course
and pursuing an understanding
in Cloud computing
is to gain certifications and
new employment opportunities
in the Cloud.
So from an individual
standpoint,
learning about the Cloud
and leveraging the Cloud
can be really valuable, from
a job security standpoint.
All of these badges here, these
are different certifications
you can get through AWS.
There's probably even more today
than when I pulled this image.
They're constantly
adding new things.
And these are really
awesome things to pursue.
They're not easy-- in
this class, for context,
it's kind of sitting at this
Cloud practitioner level.
You won't have all
of the knowledge
necessary to take
this exam, but you'll
have quite a bit of the
base knowledge for it.
A little bit of effort
and studying outside,
which you can reach out
to me if you want to,
have some more research on
that, resources on that.
But a little bit of study and
you should be able to take that.
And once you've taken the
Cloud practitioner exam,
then you can move on to
some of these associate
and then professional exams.
But either way, it's
all to say that one
of the promises of the
Cloud was that it was going
to reduce the need,
the labor needs,
because now all of a sudden,
we've consolidated this.
So we don't need--
every company doesn't need
to have their own Cloud
engineer because we all share
the same Cloud resources.
But the reality is, and as
we'll learn through this course,
and why we even have a course
on this is it's a lot of work
still.
There's a lot of
knowledge to be gained
of how to do this effectively
and how to leverage
the Cloud effectively.
So a lot of job opportunities
for individuals,
but from a company
side of things,
it's not always
necessarily the best thing,
because while you think
you're cutting back
on the number of
employees, you're
probably going to have to hire
on a bunch of Cloud engineers
or system architects still.
So again, pros and cons.
But I just wanted to highlight
some of those initial big hits.
And again, we're focusing
on AWS in this course.
There's not anything
that special about them.
They're one of the first,
if not the first big player
to the space of Cloud computing.
They certainly still have
the largest market share.
It's waning as far as their
lead on everybody else,
but still probably
comfortably a third,
depending on how you
define it, of the internet
is running through AWS.
So it's a great
platform to learn.
It's, again, widely used.
That's the only platform
I used in my past company.
So Carvana, Maxar,
Striveworks, we only used AWS,
but you could go work at a
bunch of different companies
and they would use
any other platforms.
So I'm not by any means a shill.
I'm not getting paid by
AWS to teach this course,
but it's just a platform that
I'm the most comfortable with.
The good thing is--
I mean, honestly, all the
platforms are the same.
I've used the other ones as
well too for different things,
for smaller tasks, and
a little bit of Googling
and you find the
exact same thing.
And honestly, it's a good idea
for a final project as well.
If you're interested
in the trade
offs between these
platforms, I'm
very open to you exploring doing
something we did in this course,
but on one of the
other platforms.
So Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud Project
are probably the two other
biggest ones in this space,
but there are more
than that, certainly.
As you can see here, they have
a very similar certification
process, too.
They have the foundational
certification,
the associate certification, and
then professional certifications
at Google Cloud Project.
So this is just to show they're
fundamentally the same thing.
And finally here, a
bunch of different
Cloud computing careers.
And these, again, are only those
that I would argue are directly
leveraging the Cloud, but
there are countless others
that are going to be
interacting with it
or pulling resources or touching
small pieces of the Cloud
as well, too.
So again, we're going
to cover probably
something related
to all of these
at some point in this course.
They will not be
holistically covered.
But for example, if you're
taking a programming course
right now, one of our
Python programming courses,
you're probably
leveraging AWS already,
and you're going to
certainly learn ways
that you can leverage
AWS even further.
If you're taking
some of my machine
learning courses as well,
too, same kind of thing.
You can do a lot of machine
learning on your computer,
but eventually you're going
to want more resources.
And so if you have
some AWS experience,
it's going to be really nice
and allow you to build on that.
So this really is a
foundational course
across a lot of
different aspects,
not only of our department, but
of just broadly the tech world.
So be open,
understand that we're
seeing small pieces
of this, but try
to find those pockets of
things that are interest to you
or careers that are
interest to you.
Feel free to let me know if
you feel like it's not being--
or something you're
interested in
is not being addressed
directly enough.
I'm happy to point you
towards more resources
or kind of adjust
things, but we'll
try to get a kind of quick,
broad overview of everything
throughout the semester.
So again, we're going to
be hitting virtual servers
and storage first-ish
in this course.
That'll really get us
the foundations for most
of the rest of the semester.
I think we actually go into
security next after that,
followed by website
hosting, and that'll
get us into development and
deployment of applications,
databases, we'll talk
plenty about that.
And that will really
build towards things
like the data warehousing
course in our department.
And then we'll finish off
with machine learning and data
science tasks in the Cloud.
So we're hitting
a wide range and I
expect no background knowledge
on any of these topics, either.
We'll certainly do a lot
of Python in this class,
but if you don't have Python
experience, don't worry at all.
I won't expect you to
write any new Python code,
if that makes sense.
All this will be
just hey, I want
to allow you guys to
see how to use this,
so I'll provide you code.
If you have programming
experience, you can build on it
or rewrite it.
If you don't, you can
take it at face value
and just focus on
the parts that we're
going to be teaching in this
course, the Cloud aspects.
So finally, this is
absolute last slide here,
but I just want you to
take this chance now
to, if you haven't already,
spin up a personal AWS account.
If you already have one, great.
No need to worry about anything.
I think the first
assignment that we'll
have you submit, kind of
confirmation that you have done
or have set up an AWS account
in some capacity for yourself.
That way we can hit
the ground running
with these first examples
as we dig into it.
Recognize that there are--
you'll have to put a
credit card on file
when you create this
account, because there are
paid resources in the Cloud.
I'll be very intentional
in discussing
how to avoid any charges.
There are a bunch of
things that the free tier.
If you Google free
tier AWS, you'll
see a whole page dedicated
to all the free things
you have access to.
There's nothing
we're going to do
in this course that
requires you to move
outside of the free tier.
If it does require you to
move outside of the free tier,
I'll make that clear and
I'll give you an option.
There's not going to
be an expectation you
have to pay anything for this.
That being said, if you
don't shut down resources,
for example, we'll use what's
called an EC2 instance here
in a few weeks, that's a
virtual machine, a computer
in the Cloud, basically.
If you set up a virtual machine
that is really large, kind of
beyond the free tier
and let it run all day,
the costs can run
up very quickly.
So that's not to
scare you in any way.
As long as you're following
along with this course
and being intentional
and trying to make sure
you understand these things,
you won't have any costs here.
But I just want to preface
this that if you go in blindly
and just start clicking
a bunch of buttons
and not knowing what you're
doing and not talking to me,
there are potential
costs that could come in.
So please be mindful of that.
If you have any
concerns or questions,
talk to me about that.
Any hesitations or also issues
with creating your account.
If you can't get an account
created, let me know how--
or what you tried, what
didn't work, what didn't work,
and we'll try to find a
solution here quickly.
So let's try to get
this done this week
so that way it
doesn't slow down any
of the future weeks
in the semester.
So we'll leave it at that.
I'm excited about this.
If you can't tell
already, this is
one of those topics where it
unlocks so much capability
in what we can do
with the computer,
with even building businesses,
that it's absolutely--
I mean, it's helped
me, honestly.
Even teaching this course,
I've learned so much, too.
So I'm excited for you guys to
get exposed to this content.
Keep me posted on
how things are going.
Love to meet all of you,
otherwise talk to you soon.
Bye-bye.